bonsoir monsieur des prix bonsoir pierre
karl péladeau a dit hier que c'est parce
que les deux courbes rosso veut une
offre plus élevée qui se retire du
dossier
quelles sont les intentions de l'éco
brosseau avec transats
premièrement j'aimerais juste faire un
petit point à 1,25
on respecte beaucoup monsieur monsieur
péladeau on pense que c'est un
gestionnaire extraordinaire et puis
d'ailleurs notre société les cobras sow
est un actionnaire de longue date de
quebecor et puis et puis celle ci a
réalisé des très bons rendements pour
nos clients donc on respecte beaucoup
les qualités du sonneur de monsieur
péladeau
mais ayant dit ça on pense que c'est bon
que les gens réalisent là que l'offre
que monsieur péladeau déposé 2,5 dollars
par action n'est pas la même que nous
avions accepté à l'époque de la part
d'air canada et de la fondation la wii
mais mais il y avait une différence
importante et sa différence là était que
les actions étaient nous recevions des
actions d'air canada
donc à ce moment là les changes les
actions d'air canada se transigeait 17
dollar par action
et puis un autre est ville les actions
d'ing canada était fortement
sous-évaluée donc à titre indicatif
aujourd'hui les actions d'air canada se
transige à 25 $ ce qui ce qui ferait une
offre équivalente sera en action transat
aujourd'hui d'environ $ et nous pouvons
continuer de participer au processus de
création de valeur de ré deux autres
lorsque monsieur péladeau pour vous à ce
point ci n'est pas assez élevé à ce
point ici et et et dans le futur nous
croyons que transat dans sa forme
actuelle tous les éléments pour réussir
et prospérer
donc si notre position on pense que les
liquidités de transats sont adéquates et
on pense que dans les prochains mois
alors que la majorité de la population
va recevoir le vaccin
les frontières vont réouvrir on pense
que le saignement loisirs des voyages ne
devrait voir un rebond fort important
qui va fortement bénéficie transat et
ultime ans on pense que le prix de
l'action devrait aussi en bénéficient
donc à vous dire dans le futur c'est que
monsieur péladeau ne même pas à
travailler une proposition elle est déjà
refusé d'avancer coûte et on est
toujours ouvert à écouter toutes les
propositions le bien évidemment là c'est
notre devoir de fiduciaire en larmes aux
clients mais notre message c'est que
dans sa forme actuelle la société
transat a tout ce qu'il faut pour
réussir et prospérer comme un leader
mondial du tourisme avec un siège social
au québec
et puis et puis encore une fois l'offre
qui a été présentée par monsieur
péladeau et n était pas supérieur à
celle qui nous avait été présenté par
air canada il ya quelques mois je vous
fais entendre que monsieur péladeau a
dit à l'émission koh a décidé lui de
considérer que leur fera 5 $ et des
ports étaient pas intéressant je les
invite à en faire l'acquisition en
entreprise et la diriger lui-même
monsieur les deux co qui épie toilet coq
et qui est propriétaire de votre firme
les cobras rosso il invite monsieur
péladeau invite monsieur lescoat à
devenir l'actionnaire majoritaire est ce
que c'est l'intention de les cobras saut
de devenir éventuellement d'actionnaire
majoritaire de 3 est non absolument pas
nous on veut que transat encore une fois
dans sa forme actuelle on pense que
transitent tous les éléments pour
réussir les liquidités sont adéquates
on supporte l'équipe de gestion en place
lire on a aucune intention de privatiser
transat là encore une fois dans sa forme
actuelle avec les liquidités avec le le
rebond le fort rebond du trafic aérien
on pense que le prix des actions transat
est très attrayant ce niveau aussi et on
a ici ce qui explique notre notre
intention de conserver nos actions
est-ce que vous souhaitez négocier
espérer une autre offre de votre côté
une autre proposition qui pourrait
tomber pour transat
encore une fois nous notre focus est
vraiment sur la création de valeur sur
le long terme et puis et puis on pense
que transat tout ce qu'il faut pour
réussir et puis on n'a pas besoin
on n'a pas besoin de notre offre pour
que ce soit l'on pense que les
liquidités de 700 millions sont plus
qu'adéquate on pense que dans les
prochains mois on va assister un fort
rebond du tourisme et puis du trafic
aérien et puissent on peut voir avec
notre expérience au show de la frontière
qu'est ce qui se produit et puis aussi
transat juste avant la pandémie là il
faut se rappeler qu'ils avaient fait des
investissements importants dans leur
flotte vous avez vrai génie leur fleuve
simplifier leur flotte
ce qui nous est que des coûts
d'opération love on est beaucoup plus
faible
donc nous on est très confiant dans les
perspectives sur le transat dans sa
fortune première de les cobras saut à
notre émission on est très content nous
avons reçu monsieur des prix en espérant
vous recevoir sur d'autres dossiers
parce que vous êtes quand même un
actionnaire est un acteur de
l'investissement au québec important
vous investi dans plusieurs secteurs
absolument donc on est une société place
malki d'investissement qui était fondée
en 1900
87 des puits et puis on est très présent
sur la scène québécoise canadienne et
aussi des espoirs au niveau mondial et
puis on est reconnu pour une perspective
prendre une vue très long terme et puis
se concentrer sur les fondamentaux et
essayer le bruit le plus possible ses
bambins au plaisir de vous reparler
merci michel després merci beaucoup
en soirée pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici r d